y
[Música]
el 80% de las viviendas de mariupol
están destruidas según las autoridades
uno de los lugares bombardeados fue el
teatro donde se refugiaban al menos 1000
civiles los rescatistas buscan
sobrevivientes
el expresidente peruano alberto fujimori
fue indultado y saldrá de prisión el
máximo tribunal constitucional aprobó la
solicitud de la defensa que pedía
eliminar la suspensión del indulto que
le dieron al ex mandatario en 2017
radio francia internacional y france 24
estará a punto de ser suspendidas de
malí la junta militar comenzó un
procedimiento contra las cadenas
públicas francesas a las que acusa de
desestabilizar la transición el grupo lo
niega
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y comenzamos el
mariupol el ayuntamiento de la ciudad
ucraniana de estima que el 80% de las
viviendas están destruidas por los
bombardeos rusos el más reciente ataque
aéreo fue contra un teatro donde se
resguardaban al menos 1000 civiles hoy
un funcionario de la oficina del alcalde
afirmó que cientos de personas quedaron
vivas sin embargo todavía no se sabe
cuántas murieron
un ataque deliberado contra posiciones
civiles según denunció ucrania esta
imagen de satélite tomada antes del
bombardeo atribuido a rusia muestra la
palabra niñas escrita en letras blancas
gigantes a ambos lados del teatro drama
en mariupol el miércoles del edificio
fue destruido en gran parte por las
bombas lo que las autoridades han
calificado de crimen de guerra la única
palabra para describir lo que ha
ocurrido hoy es genocidio genocidio
contra nuestra nación de nuestro pueblo
ucraniano se estima que más de 1000
personas buscaban refugio en el interior
del teatro el número de muertos es por
ahora desconocido rusia niega haber
bombardeado el teatro y en cambio acusa
al batallón ucraniano de extrema derecha
a soft de atacar a su propio pueblo y
usarlos como escudos humanos
es imposible encontrar palabras para
describir el nivel de sí mismo y
crueldad con el que los invasores rusos
están destruyendo a los pacíficos
residentes de una ciudad ucraniana junto
al mar
ha pasado dos semanas desde que las
fuerzas rusas rodearon por primera vez
la ciudad portuaria del sureste del país
mariupol es ahora una sombra de lo que
fue los edificios han quedado reducidos
a escombros el acceso es casi imposible
alrededor de 300.000 personas están
atrapadas con suministros cada vez más
escasos de alimentos y agua
en uno de los pocos centros médicos que
sirven operando en la ciudad los
pacientes son atendidos de los pasillos
las mujeres dan a luz rodeadas de
heridos y el sótano se ha convertido en
una morgue la ms verificó 43 ataques en
la guerra contra centros de salud sin
embargo rusia dice que no bombardea
ciudades y reiteró que no es el
responsable del ataque aéreo contra el
teatro en mariupol en usar sus cultivos
6-4 félix chang stephen jackson
el régimen de quiet trató inmediatamente
de atribuir la culpa de todo lo ocurrido
en mario pool y en particular de la
voladura del teatro de drama en mariupol
a los militares rusos que se ve en su
visión supuestamente lanzaron una bomba
aérea sobre el edificio del teatro por
supuesto eso es una mentira las fuerzas
armadas rusas no bombardean ciudades y
todo el mundo es consciente de ello no
importa cuántos vídeos se dicen en las
estructuras de la otan cuantas ediciones
e imágenes falsas se difundan la verdad
se abrirá paso de todos modos haremos
todo lo posible para evitar que esos
crímenes queden impunes
mediante este primer proyecto ha dicho
que hasta la casa mykolaiv es una ciudad
estratégica en el sur de ucrania si las
fuerzas rusas la controlan tendrán
acceso directo por tierra a la ciudad
portuaria de odessa y también la
totalidad del acceso al mar de ucrania
el informe desde nuestros enviados
especiales
las sirenas alertan de una nueva amenaza
sobre mikko live es una señal de que se
debe buscar protección como lo hace este
grupo de madres e hijas que pasan la
mayor parte del tiempo en estos refugios
legados de la segunda guerra mundial
nos
da mucho miedo durante la noche quedarse
en casa tenemos niños por eso venimos
aquí también durante el día
y los niños se sienten aquí más
protegidos que en la casa de sitios
elisabeth no solamente teme por su hija
cada alarma le recuerda que su marido
está en el frente defendiendo la ciudad
tenemos miedo de las explosiones
punto de las explosiones cercanas a
nosotros
tenemos mucho miedo
estoy en camino a visitar su apartamento
que tuvo que abandonar días atrás cuando
fue atacado por una serie de misiles
rusos
esto es muy peligroso en cada jardín ha
caído un cohete
la mitad de la población de 500.000
habitantes abandonado mykolaiv una
ciudad estratégica para moscú
si la controla podrá tener acceso
directo al puerto de odessa y cerrar la
comunicación del resto de ucrania con el
mar pero amor adquiere prima papa daña
aquí impacto del cohete directamente
éste fue lanzado desde una población a
más o menos 70 kilómetros
de tapachula
luego viene a darle vuelta a su casa o
inhabitables
cuenta que celebró su 70 cumpleaños en
uno de esos refugios subterráneos
no tengo ninguna opción para irme del
país no tengo familiares ni amigos en el
extranjero no quiero convertirme en una
molestia para nadie por eso me quedaré a
la espera de mejores tiempos
a las afueras de la morgue esta familia
llora la muerte del padre de anna
estaba en un colegio y una bomba cayó en
el edificio tax sólo pudimos encontrarlo
a los tres días solo hoy el destino de
mykolaiv es clave para el futuro de
ucrania y aquí saben que el precio que
tendrán que pagar por ello es bastante
grande temen incluso el asedio como ya
sucede en la ciudad cercana de mario
pool
[Música]
en otras noticias el expresidente
peruano alberto fujimori saldrá de
prisión el tribunal constitucional
aprobó un recurso legal que le da un
indulto humanitario el ex mandatario
cumplía desde 2009 una condena de 25
años por ser el autor intelectual de dos
masacres desde el imán nuestro
corresponsal francisco zacarías nos
explicó previamente por qué será
liberado fujimori y qué implicaciones
tiene esto
el tribunal constitucional de perú
concedió un habeas corpus al ex
presidente alberto fujimori estable
restituye el indulto otorgado por el ex
presidente pedro pablo kuczynski en el
año 2017 fujimori venía cumpliendo una
condena de 25 años por los casos de la
cantuta y barrios altos con la sentencia
del tribunal constitucional le
corresponde a la corte suprema trasladar
el fallo al instituto penitenciario para
la liberación de alberto fujimori que se
podría ejecutar en las próximas horas
para algunos juristas la sentencia del
tribunal constitucional no corresponde
porque la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos señala que los crímenes
de lesa humanidad deben ser investigados
juzgados y sancionados y se destaca que
no se le puede aplicar ningún tipo de
indulto amnistía ni perdón en este
sentido expertos locales afirman que la
liberación de alberto fujimori puede ser
anulado por la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos por el lado del
fujimorismo exigen que se respete el
fallo porque manifiestan que fujimori no
fue procesado por un delito de lesa
humanidad y su condena es de homicidio
calificado en la calidad de autor
mediato en las próximas horas vamos a
ver qué reacciones se van a registrar
mientras tanto algunos simpatizantes de
fujimori están rodeando la clínica donde
venía siendo atendido así como el lugar
donde ha venido purgando prisión todos
estos años por otra parte los deudos y
familiares de los casos conocidos como
la cantuta y barrios altos señalan que
van a apelar a los tribunales
internacionales para que puedan obtener
justicia finalmente
hoy se cumplen 30 años del atentado
contra la embajada de israel en buenos
aires el 17 de marzo de 1992
fundamentalistas islámicos hicieron
explotar un coche-bomba contra la
edificación desde el lugar donde estaba
la embajada nuestro corresponsal natalio
pues hoy nos cuenta cómo se conmemora la
fecha
el sonido de esta sirena marca las 14 50
hora argentina
ahora comienza a sonar el himno
argentino aquí frente a lo que era la
embajada de israel que hace 30 años
sufrió el primer ataque en su tipo en
argentina y en américa latina' un ataque
con bomba que destruyó del edificio en
el que ahora hay una plaza conmemorativa
en ese ataque murieron 29 personas y
hubo más de 200 heridos ocurrió en el
año 1992 según israel el ataque fue
perpetrado por el grupo libanés
hezbollah y también por iran pero la
justicia argentina no ha podido
determinar quiénes fueron los autores
aquí de ese atentado de hecho dos años
después en 1994 nuevo ataque con bomba
esta vez en la asociación mutual
israelita argentina una organización
comunitaria judía en este país que es el
que tiene la mayor población
de américa latina' como decía una bomba
en la asociación mutual y realista
argentina dejó 85 personas muertas y 300
heridos otra vez un caso que no ha sido
aún resuelto por la justicia argentina y
aquí se pide justicia y memoria 30 años
después del atentado a la embajada de
israel
el gobierno de malí anunció su intención
de suspender en el país las señales de
france 24 y radio francia internacional
rf y les acusan de venir contra las
fuerzas armadas e incluso las comparan
con la radio que alentó el genocidio en
ruanda en 1994 sin embargo la cadena
pública francesa y la unión europea
rechazaron las acusaciones mientras que
el presidente francés emmanuel mccomb
condenó la decisión el informe es de
lluís muchos de france 24 y radio
francia internacional a punto de ser
suspendidos de malí por la junta militar
la anunció a través de un comunicado
teniendo en cuenta la sincronización de
este bombo mediático el gobierno deduce
de ello una estrategia premeditada para
desestabilizar la transición
desmoralizar al pueblo maliense y
desacreditar a las valientes fuerzas
armadas
la junta acusa de mentir y se basa en
tres fuentes una declaración de la alta
comisionada para los derechos humanos de
las naciones unidas michele bachelet un
informe human rights watch y un
reportaje de rf
el grupo de comunicación público francés
negó las acusaciones y explorará todas
las formas de recurso un rechazo que
llegó hasta la unión europea
lo consideramos inaceptable lamentamos
de esta decisión y las acusaciones
infundadas al atacar la libertad de
prensa de informar y ser informado la
junta continúa y confirma su huida hacia
adelante ntx este martes 15 de marzo en
el informe de human rigth watch se dijo
que desde diciembre de 2021 el ejército
de mali había sido responsable de la
muerte de 71 civiles un reporte
publicado un mes después del anuncio de
la retirada de tropas francesas de malí
la presencia de francia en malí se
remonta a 2013 cuando intervino en el
norte del país contra los extremistas
islámicos
allí disponía de 2.400 soldados de los
4.300 que ha tenido en distintos puntos
del sahel así migoya al líder de la
junta llegó al poder en agosto de 2020 y
en un segundo golpe de estado destituyó
a los líderes civiles desde entonces
y del sentimiento antifrancés
apoyamos a nuestros líderes francia no
debe permanecer más en mali de hecho en
el comunicado de expulsión contra
france24 y radio francia internacional
son comparados con la radio mil calling
que alentó el genocidio en ruanda de
francia puede hacer la diferencia en el
punto de inflexión en el que está el
mundo esas fueron las palabras del
presidente francés emmanuel bajo durante
su nuevo evento de campaña afirma que si
es reelegido guiará al país a través de
la nueva crisis nuestra corresponsal en
francia- natalia ruiz tiene toda la
información mack contra dejó pocas
sorpresas más bien más continuidad y
sobre todo adaptado a lo que está
sucediendo actualmente en europa en
especial en términos de la crisis
energética donde propone que para 2050
ya francia no dependa de energías
fósiles además de esto habrá un aumento
también en el gasto de defensa aunque no
dio cifras precisas el otro punto
importante de este programa es la
educación en donde la mamá con quiere
que los maestros tengan una mejor
remuneración y haya una inversión mucho
más importante en educación superior y
también en investigación por supuesto
hablo de esa reforma pensional y reiteró
su deseo de que la edad de pensión suba
a los 65 años tres años más de lo que
ella es actualmente pero eso esté
acompañado por un mínimo de jubilación
que estaría en los 1.100 euros en cuanto
a continuidad bueno manuel malcolm
quiere un proyecto que se inscriba en el
marco de una sociedad mucho más
igualitaria en donde haya mayor
protección de la infancia y también
donde el sistema de salud sea mucho más
eficaz en términos de prevención las
novedades vinieron más cuando se refirió
a la inmigración con unas reglas mucho
más estrictas para otorgar las visas de
larga estadía y para aquellas personas
que hayan hecho una petición de asilo y
ésta le sea denegada tendrán la
obligación de salir del territorio
francés cierto es que durante tres horas
después de haber presentado su programa
de manuel mejor respondió a las
preguntas de los más de 300 periodistas
que estaban aquí en esta sala y mostró
que en realidad conoce los temas al
derecho y al revés el que sigue
punteando en todos los sondeos tanto en
la primera la primera como en la segunda
vuelta sin embargo se le preguntó qué
pasaría si ha pensado qué pasaría si no
llega a ganar dijo que por ahora no se
le ha atravesado esa idea por la cabeza
y que en caso de ser así tendría que
tomarse un tiempo antes de saber qué
haría después
y así llegamos al final de nuestra
emisión informativa los invitamos a que
consulten más información en france 24
punto com nos vemos pronto
[Música]